The joe rogan experience.
Interesting. Gorgeous.
George was crazy. Yeah. Interesting.
Was a stupid ad. You have to
watch for the Olympics there. Boy,
I'm this Olympics is,
I think I'm going to say this.
I think the Olympics are gross. This
is why I think the Olympics are gross.
I think it's a great opportunity
for all those athletes.
I think it's great for people to watch it,
but I think it is a fucking disgusting
money grab and all those amateur air
quotes.
Athletes don't get paid shit with them
and these companies are making billions
and billions of dollars off of them
and I really wish they would all quit.
I really wish they would say,
fuck you pay me.
I really wish they would just go
straight ray Liotta they give a fuck.
You pay me. They get up there.
They're youth for that. Not only that,
the fucking companies,
they're so restrictive,
they're the IOC and all the people that
are behind it are so restrictive and
they are making ungodly sums of money,
ungodly contracts.
They're just giant contracts to air the,
the Olympics,
giant amounts of money to
build the stadiums and set up,
these are these events and that everything
is about net nationalism and national
pride, whether it's in Korea or Russia
or wherever the fuck they do them.
But meanwhile, the athletes don't
get dick. They don't get Dick.
If you're lucky and you're Michael Phelps,
you become famous out of it.
And you get a bunch of commercials,
commercials and endorsements and you
make a shit load of money that way.
But how many Michael Phelps is, are there
was a three or four, I mean how many,
but how many in the, all
the, all the Olympics and out
of all the Olympics, Jamie,
you're a sports fan at all the Olympics,
say like the Olympics this year. Well,
let's go to the last one.
Who the fuck came out of it?
Where they're a household name?
Right now you've got Shaun white
and maybe I heard of that guy.
The girl that won, uh,
Kim is her last name
last night or two nights before the
real famous. Uh, there's Lindsey Vaughn,
she's very famous.
She's very famous that she,
she used to date tiger woods that
made her famous too. Plus she's hot.
That makes her famous. It's
peekaboo. Straight Shit.
Interesting names. So like her,
she's a gold medal winner, I believe.
How many other ones out of there?
There's a few.
I mean there's like a handful.
They can build a story around someone,
then they can tell the story.
But when you get to the point where
it's worthwhile to sacrifice your entire
life and it actually pays off,
what are the, what are the odds?
It's so fucking small, but meanwhile
people are tuning in to all of it.
They're making massive amounts of revenue
from all of it and they're not sharing
it with the athletes at all.
I think it's fucking gross.
They pretend it's amateur.
Different tenants and amateur.
It's a Goddamn motherfucking business.
That's what the Olympics are. Well,
there's considerable college business.
You can't basketball and football.
Really?
NCAA says student athletes shouldn't be
paid because the 13th amendment allows
unpaid prison labor. What the
fuck? Oh, that's Shaun King.
This is breaking up. This is
a, this is another article.
This was the main one going around,
but there's uh, uh, that's crazy.
Did they really say that? Did they
really say that? The 13th amendment,
which allows unpaid prison
labor decided in a lawsuit,
a response to a motion
to dismiss and they,
that's what they use is so disgusting.
They're so disgusting.
They're the same to me. Ncaa College
football and basketball, same thing to me.
They have 180 of those thousand people.
Yeah, fuck you pay those guys, pay him,
pay those girls, pay all those
athletes. You're making money,
you're making money and you're
not sharing it with the athletes.
They might as well be slaves.
They might as well be fucking prisoners,
the Olympics, Ncaa, all that
shit. It's just these no way.
There's no way you could
do that fresh today.
Have you started from
scratch today and said,
we're going to get make billions of
dollars and we're going to give you boom.
Got It. Gotcha. Cool.
There was no way you
could never do education.
Imagine they did that with the
Olympics today. They said, look,
we're going to spend billions
of dollars in the athletes.
What are they going to pay? Oh,
we're not going to pay them shit.
They don't get anything. You remember just
to be making any money. You're fucked.
You're out. It used to be that
you made money, you're out,
but now they let basketball
players play in the Olympics.
They like the NBA players because of,
I think it was Russia was getting
close and beat and they beat us once.
[inaudible] 72 I think. Oh, is that what
it was? They started thinking about it.
Then when we got, they were catching up.
The European players were catching up.
They go, fuck this. We're going
to send over our brothers.
NBC Sports is about to make one point $4
billion in 22 days thanks to the super
bowl and the winter Olympics.
Okay. The Superbowl,
at least his professional athletes,
I guess they get paid,
they get paid and whether they get paid
enough is up for debate. I get that,
but the Olympics,
they're not getting paid dick and it's
fucking gross and it makes me angry and
it's one of the reasons why I don't watch
the Olympics. I get mad at it. You know,
I wanted to be in the Olympics at
one point in time, but to fight,
I wanted to be in taekwondo was being
introduced the Olympics in 1988 I tried
out for the national team. I got it
to like the quarter finals in Miami.
I won three fights and it
was, um, that was the last,
like my last,
uh,
my really last fascination with taekwondo.
I'd kind of given up on
taekwondo really before it.
Okay.